a show of unity between germany and
ukraine things had become strained after
berlin was criticized for sending mixed
messages about russia's aggression
no ambiguity here though the chancellor
making clear moscow must step back
i am making it clear once again here in
kiev that ukraine's sovereignty and
territorial integrity are non-negotiable
for
germany but any ideas ukraine would give
up aspirations to join nato as had
apparently been floated by the country's
ambassador to the uk
was scotched by president zielenski
ukraine's desire to join the european
union to strengthen its borders for
future alliance and our ambitions you
are very well aware of it it is the
country's wish also there is a war in
the east we understand and we would like
nato membership which would be a
guarantee of our security
with ukraine maintaining its red lines
then no one knows how this will end
but nato is reinforcing its eastern
european members
this consignment of military hardware
arriving in lithuania
this crisis is clearly entering a
critical phase as the diplomacy gains
greater urgency
but it's hard at the moment to see how a
breakthrough will come when all of the
issues that led to this confrontation in
the first place remain unchanged
and all the time ordinary ukrainians can
only wait nervously
hoping that war will not come
warnings of an imminent russian attack
are just as loud
the kremlin has the firepower in place
now but says these operations in belarus
on ukraine's border are just military
exercises
trying to decipher vladimir putin's
intentions
has become a guessing game in ukraine
but these protesters say the world needs
to know it's one that could have deadly
consequences
the west is under attack it's not
russian aggression against ukraine it's
against western civilization so either
we win together
or then
everybody will be paid a big price
but prime minister boris johnson warned
europe it must end its addiction to
russian gas
if it's to have any leverage over moscow
we need to find alternative sources of
energy and we need to get ready to
impose some very very severe economic
consequences on on russia
there could though be a glint of hope
russia's foreign minister sergey lavrov
meeting with the russian leader stated
that the diplomacy is far from exhausted
but it's hard to see how the west can
force the kremlin to de-escalate without
caving into some of its key demands
and people here know what that might
mean
the end of the dream of a european
future
alex rossi sky news kiev